meanwhile joe biden did wrong on
coronavirus dead wrong on the governors
that are good on coronavirus
dead wrong on even conveying that
message about coronavirus
joe biden wants you to be very grateful
to him
because before biden came into office oh
man kovit it was a total mess we had
nothing you know there was just
there was no vaccine well i mean there
was and
you know we didn't have it under control
uh we did
and we you know had deaths in excess of
the predictions uh no that's not true
the deaths were actually way below the
predictions
but in any case you got to thank joe
biden
just over four weeks ago america had no
real plan to vaccinate most of the
country
my predecessors my mother would say god
love them failed to order enough
vaccines
failed to mobilize the effort to
administer the shots
failed to set up vaccine centers that
changed the moment we took office
so notice the shift here notice the
shift
they used to attack trump because the
deaths were going to be
higher than the predictions remember but
the predictions were like
2 million deaths you know within just a
matter of months and that just didn't
happen
the real numbers were much much lower so
they couldn't go after trump on that
so then they went after trump on uh his
his own policies you know the travel
policies but
trump's policies reduced the the number
of infections and deaths right because
trump was the one who said we're going
to shut down travel from china we're
going to shut down travel from europe
actually over democrat opposition
so they can't they can't really attack
him on that then they attack him on the
vaccine
but trump came out and said we're going
to have a vaccine by the fall
it was the democrats who said that's not
possible including joe biden joe biden
people are forgetting this now because
the left rewrites history because they
lie about it and then
their lackeys in the media do the work
of actually rewriting it
and erasing the old questions and you
know pushing that down the memory hole
but joe biden was skeptical that there
would be a vaccine forget by the fall
that there would be a vaccine any time
in 2020 that maybe by the very end of
2020 maybe there'd be a vaccine but who
knows
the week before last the head of the
centers for disease control dr redfield
said it would be
summer before the vaccine would become
generally available
to the public you said that he was
confused
and mistaken those were your two words
but
dr slowy the head of your operation worf
speed
has said exactly the same thing are they
both wrong well i've spoken to the
companies and we can have it a lot
sooner it's a very political thing
because people like this
would rather make it political than save
lives this man is talking about a
vaccine
every serious every serious company is
talking about
maybe having a vaccine done by the end
of the year but the distribution of that
vaccine
will not occur until sometime beginning
or the middle of next year to get it out
if we get the vaccine and pray god we
will may god
mr vice president i want to pick up
though you'll have the vaccine i want to
pick up
this is an amazing clip i hope that you
save it i want you if you're watching
this
take this clip it out save it to your
desktop if you're listening
on audio podcasts record it on your
phone because they're going to try to
get rid of this clip
chris wallace says the head of the cdc
and the head of the operation warp speed
president trump say that there's no way
you're going to get a vaccine
out this year and it's not going to
become available to the public until
next summer
what you what are you saying that you
know better than your top
genius scientists and trump says yes i
do know better than them
they're wrong we're going to get it out
much quicker we're going to get the
vaccine by the fall
and we're going to get it out to the
public not not too long thereafter
are you crazy oh my gosh and trump said
no i'm not crazy this is what's going to
happen
this is what's i know this because i
talk to these people in my office every
day
and you guys you chris wallace and you
joe biden
and you democratic media are just trying
to make this political
so that you can score some points but
i'm right and they're all wrong
the scientific establishment the media
and the democratic party wrong
trump right and guess what it turns out
he was correct then
joe biden who's a little bit cageier
here right
he says well you know i'm talking about
when the vaccine is going to come out
we're not going to get that out for
quite a while now
the vaccine did start coming out not
long after
you know to the public not long after it
was announced and by the way when was
the vaccine discovery announced
days after the election sounds pretty
political to me too
but even given that it was days after
you're talking about the early days of
november
the vaccine was announced much sooner
than biden the democrats and the media
pretended it would be if you enjoyed
that break from disinformation
historical revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button
so that you never miss another video
[Music]
you